welcome to an introduction to omics
logic a little bit about me my name is
laura murray as elia mentioned i am the
educational program coordinator here at
pine biotech
i have a background in gaining my
bachelor's degree in microbiology and
i'm currently finishing up my master's
degree in biology and bioinformatics
my focus and areas of expertise are in
metagenomics transcriptomics and
genomics
and my most recent research was in
analyzing the metagenomics of deep sea
hydrothermal vents
and which bacterial communities reside
there
so in this presentation i will explain
the current challenges and limitations
in bioinformatics
i will describe how we aim to address
these challenges with the omex logic
portal
i will describe bloom's taxonomy for
learn learning progression and how it
can be used in bioinformatics coursework
we will explore the omixlogic portal and
how it utilizes bloom's taxonomy and
structuring its courses
pipelines and projects
and finally i will describe several
outcomes of the omics logic portal
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets that are analyzed are also
usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers just don't
have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists don't have
in the university setting students have
the opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but don't receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations mentioned previously
similarly faculty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics especially if they are
specialized in a certain area of
bioinformatics or if they are unfamiliar
with bioinformatics in general
for example a professor whose research
focuses on oncogene expression might not
know much about the meta genomics of
seawater
so in order to overcome these challenges
the omixologic portal was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analyses usable for
any biologist or clinician
there are some traditional problems with
the standardization of bioinformatics
coursework
materials for courses are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
and are rarely updated
the omixlogic portal introduces new
material that keeps up with new
technology
these courses also need to be organized
because the challenge is to combine
several different topics together the
flow and transitions between subjects
needs to be developed
this is addressed at omics logic through
introductory material being woven
throughout the course
the last challenge we face is
systemization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or allow
someone to run forward
to address this omixlogic uses
standardized modules and interactive
sessions beginning with mastering
terminology and concepts to implementing
these concepts with real data sets in a
project-based approach
so here's an overview of the learning
process so in order to create a clear
path of skill development omics logic
employs the bloom's taxonomy levels of
learning
this approach starts with the basics
students recall facts and terminology
and are able to repeat and memorize the
material
with this base the learning builds to
conceptual knowledge being able to
understand concepts and apply
information to new situations
the student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods
this leads them to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
so how do omixlogic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path at the
bloom's taxonomy pyramid
no matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is
omixlogic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets
an introduction to basic coding
languages like r and python or beginning
a data analysis project
so these six courses were taken from the
core omixlogic curriculum available
online
beginning with an introduction to the
applications of bioinformatics in an
overview of data types the student is
able to learn terminology and factual
knowledge to build upon from there
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and data science are
introduced
each course starts with important terms
and concepts and then introduces case
studies and pipelines related to each
one
this allows the student to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own projects
so omixlogic also expands upon its basic
core curriculum with specialization
track projects bioinformatics methods
are best learned in the context of real
case studies prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various bioinformat
bioinformatics methods and omics data
types are used in current research both
in medicine and in biotechnology
agriculture and even astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenge and the analysis path
to extract meaningful insights from
complex omics data
the omixlogic portal gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
either a codependent path or a code
independent path
these datasets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
so like i mentioned you can learn
bioinformatics without coding at any
coding experience at all for that in
each project we explain the analysis
pipelines on the user-friendly t-bioinfo
platform for big data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean and visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like r and python in
order to create your own analyses
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mentor guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
so here's an example of the code
independent pipeline the pipeline
builder interface on the t bioinfo
platform is a color-coded pipeline that
helps establish a logical connection
between the technical names of data
analysis methods and the logical steps
needed to build the fold pipeline
data is put in as an input file and then
analyses can be chosen based off of the
type of research
each analysis is separated into three
colors
blue for pre-processing red for mapping
and green for quantification each time
you click a button a pop-up will contain
additional information useful for
building the pipeline
the ease of the color-coded buttons
allows programs to be run without any
coding knowledge
interactive outputs allow for easy
visualization of the data
several demo pipelines with real data
sets are available for students to
practice the workflow including demos on
genomic variant calling of cancer cell
lines
16s amplicon analysis on diet and its
effects on the microbiome and a pipeline
for examining a phylogenetic analysis of
ebola virus
so after using the tbiwinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge the remember
and understand level of blooms
and apply that in a project the apply
analyze and evaluate level of blooms
then students are able to check their
comprehension with levels and badges
certificates of completion and tests
similarly faculty could be should be
able to assign the omixlogic portal to
their students with the understanding
that it will give them holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with the bytes
and molecules course and on to designing
their own question based project
so omixlogic employs a hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are building off of
the first level of bloom's taxonomy
omics logic tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews quizzes on topics key
terms and important questions and covers
a broad range of topics like biomedical
research biotechnology and agriculture
then students are able to continue their
knowledge base with a research
assessment making sure they are able to
understand methods challenges and
results as well as being able to
comprehend primary research literature
and recreate the methodology
they should be able to ask questions
based on data exploration this leads to
the ability to encounter errors in their
analysis
apply theoretical knowledge of why those
errors are occurring and find a solution
bioinformatics uniquely combines life
science terms with data science skills
which allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis methods
so omics logic research fellows are able
to ask research questions about any
bioinformatics topic leading to a
diverse range of projects from analyzing
affected biological pathways and
multiple sclerosis to brain metastases
due to small cell lung cancer these
students are able to apply what they've
learned in the coursework work with a
group of professional mentors and submit
their projects on the portal for review
so students should then be able to reach
the highest level of bloom's taxonomy
create
this is achieved through the creation of
their own analysis project for example
cement dolonier an undergraduate
research at belchesia university in
istanbul turkey who finished her
omixlogic training was able to work on a
project involving chronic lymphocytic
leukemia a type of blood cancer that has
a very heterogeneous biological
background and diverse treatment
strategies
from her work with omics logic samea's
work was able to be published with the
columbia undergraduate science journal
here at first she elicited 870
significantly differentially expressed
protein coding genes that were involved
in the biogenesis and processing of rna
consequently these findings led our
study to investigate non-coding rna 33
long non-coding rnas were found to be
significantly differentially expressed
among two conditions based on
differential gene expression analysis
so not only does omics logic collaborate
with undergraduate students as seen with
cma but projects with graduate students
and other researchers are common as well
here is a poster presentation for a
project done in collaboration between
naguchi memorial institute for medical
research and pine biotech
here's our team at pine biotech who are
involved with the project dr mohit
mazumdar dr harpreet kaur and elia
brodsky as well as our collaborators at
the university of ghona dr anita gansa
and dr benedicta mensah
this poster was on plasmodium falcibrium
the parasite causing malaria in its
apical membrane antigen the roctry neck
two protein binding which is a critical
interaction for plasmodium falcipromyzoa
invasion of the human host red blood
cells
several proposed malaria vaccine
candidates are designed to prevent such
finding in limit merizoa entry which
have been studied with variable success
at in vitro in early clinical trial
stages
by performing haplotype network analysis
of genomic sequencing data from sites
with variable infection rates comparing
our data with malaria gen repository
from another region in ghana
and mapping genomic variants onto the
protein structures they arrived at
preliminary conclusions about local
variation and immunogenic epitope
affecting variants for consideration
in this poster preliminary findings were
shared that suggest that genomic data
can be used to develop a local strategy
for efficacious vaccine design against
pfelcipram blood stage infection in
ghana and surrounding regions
so omixlogic is proud to collaborate
with many diverse programs across the
globe
we also work with over 15 000 students
at community college like glendale
community college top tier universities
like georgetown university as well as 20
universities around the world
omixlogic is also proud to partner with
nappy the national association of idea
principal investigators
nappy seeks to elevate bioinformatics
research in areas of the us that are
traditionally underfunded for example in
puerto rico
louisiana
and west virginia
nabi puts an emphasis on inclusion
making sure that as many people have the
opportunity to get involved with
bioinformatics research as possible
omixlogic is proud to mirror that
emphasis of inclusion with adding many
free course options
giving students asynchronous resources
to complete whenever their busy schedule
allows and pairing them with
professional mentors who can offer
guidance in getting involved in the
field of bioinformatics
so in this presentation i explained a
bit about the current challenges and
limitations in bioinformatics
i described how we aim to address these
challenges with the omics logic platform
we discussed bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in bioinformatics coursework
we also explored the omixlogic program
fundamentals and how it utilizes bloom's
taxonomy and structuring its courses
pipelines and projects
and we finally described several
outcomes of the omics logic program
so if you're wanting to know how to get
started the omics logic portal is easy
and free for anyone to register with
many courses available at no cost
there are also several upcoming programs
that as a student you can get involved
in
this is a program for data science for
biomedical data there's also one for
genomic data analysis and one on an
introduction to big data bioinformatics
as a member of faculty
please reach out to us about learning
more on integrating omixlogic courses
into your own bioinformatics curriculum
so thank you all are there any questions